[موسيقى]
ونحييكم مشاهدينا من جديد المتغيرات التي
طرات على العالم باتت محلا نقاشا بشان
موازين القوى العالميه الكاتب رجل الاعمال
الامريكي ريداريو راى ان سياده العلم سوف
تنتقل للصين عبر معايرا تعتمد على ارتفاع
المستوى التعليمي والداخلي والابتكار لكن
محللين اعتبروا انما ذكره الكاتب الامريكي
هو عبارت عن معايير كميه لا تكفي للحكم
بانتقال الهيمنه بين الدول مشيرين الى انه
لا يمكن حصره تاريخ امريكا في تاريخ
تاسيسها لانها امتداد للرياضه الاوروبيه
وذكر محللون ان امريكا ذكرت بيتنافسيه
الفكر الراسماليه والتنميه منذ تاسيسها
بخلاف
الذي اختفى في الصين وهذا فتح ثقافه قبول
الاختلاف المهاجرين وتعدد الاجناس بشكل
اوسع منها في الصين واوروبا كما ذكروا انا
ما يعتري امريكا من فورا في بعض جوانب
التعليم والصحه عيوب نتيجه عن الراسماليه
كنظام في الاساس لكن انعكاس ذلك على
المجتمع الامريكي يبقى محدودنا لانه يظل
مجتمعا مكون همم اكبر سوق في العالم ويشكل
الاستهلاك ثلث الاقتصاد الامريكي اما
الصين فبراي خبراء انها من الممكنه تكون
قوه اقليميه عظمى لكن ليست نظاما عالميا
جديدا ولو كان هناك بديل لامريكا فسيكونوا
داخل العالم الغربي وليس خارجه غير ان هذا
البديل غير حاضر لا على المدى القريب ولا
المتوسط كما ان تحول الاتحاد الاوروبي الى
دوله المتكامله غير واضحا في الافقه خبراء
[موسيقى]
نناقش هذا الموضوع مع ضيوفينا من الرياض
مثلازديري رئيس الابحاث في راجحي كابتل
اهلا بكم من موسكو الكاتب السياسيه بسام
البني اهلا
بكمين واسمحالي ان ابدا مع الاستاذ مازن
استاذ مازن حضرتك كتبت مقال تضمنا في
الواقع الكثير من النقاط الجد مهمه عرفت
في حتى بالتفاصيل الاقتصاديه
والجيو سياسيه وحتى التاريخيه كيف ان
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه ستبقى هي
الرائده في النظام العالمي عنوان المقال
لماذا سوف تبقى الرياضه للولايات المتحده
حضرتك قلت ستبقى الرياده يعني على يقين
بان امريكا هي التي ستقود العالم للفتره
القادمه لماذا هذا اليقين
قناه العربيه واهلا بالضيف من بوسكو بسام
الحقيقه انا لا استطيع اجهزه بكل شيء لكن
اعطي الاحتمال الاكبر في الجزء العالي
البقاء الرياده الامريكي في الكتاب الذي
تكلمت عنه الذي ذكرته هو ذكر الحقيقه
معايير زي ما تفضلتي اللي كتبتها انا قلت
معايير وذكر نعيم من امريكا جاءت بعد
الحرب العالميه نتيجه انها كانت القوه
العظمى العسكريه
وانا اعتقد ان هذا رايي نوعا ما سطح يعني
امريكا خسرت الحرب امام فيتنام امريكا لا
تواجه اي دوله نوويه لا تدخل في اي مواجهه
مع اي دوله نوويه
ما فقدت سيادتها على العالم لكن العالم
قبل في امريكا اراده ليش لانها خلقت نظام
راسمالي لازم نؤمن بفرضيه من العالم يريد
الراسماليه لانها تستطيع ان تجعل من الدول
حول العالم شريك تجارب وفعلا خلال
الستينات الميلاديه والخمنات نهضت المانيا
ونهضه دول اوروبا الغربيه بعد حطام الحرب
العالميه الثانيه ناهضت ونهضه اليابان نفس
الفتره في الثمانينات وما لحقها ناضت نمور
اسفين هذا الصين
فالعالم وجد بها الدوله شريك كبير حول
التنميه اذا اتفقنا ان الراس ماليه قبلت
فيها كثير من الدول ما هي استطاعت
الولايات المتحده ان يتحقق عبر الانترنت
ذكر ان نصف الجدي في العالم انه مو ناتج
الاقتصاد العالمي موجود
ناتج المحل العالم موجود في الولايات
المتحده وهذا رايته الحقيقه بعد الحرب
العالميه الثانيه كانت فرنسا وبريطاني
تمتلك مستحمرات حول العالم والثروات الخام
حول العالم اكبر من اقتصاد يعني انتاج
العالم في سنه واحده اقل من الثروهات
الخاصه حتى الان لكن الحقيقه كانت ال-
قبول كبير للولايات المتحده ثاني اذا
بنحكي هذا بالنسبه للجزئيه الرياضه
الامريكيه
المجتمع امريكا احنا كان رايي انها نتاج
من
النسيج الاوروبي اوروبا نفسها امتداد
لثقافه عمرها 25 قرن
الثقافه اليونانيه قد تكون الثقافه
الوحيده اللي في العالم لما اخذ الطبيعه
دينيه اخذت الطبيعه الانسانيه تشوفين
افكار الفلاسفه اليونانيين كلهم كانت
مرتبطه بالدنيا قوانين الرياضيات
ورجل وضع مفهوم السياسه كتاب السياسات لا
كتاب المنطق كتابه المشهور عن الفن وعن
المسرح فن الشاعر الى اخره
هذه الفكر القامت عليه القواعد الاوروبيه
من 25 سنه استمرت كان يسمى بالقران
الكلاسيكيه استمرت حتى في الزمن العصور
الوسطى لكن سيطرت عليه الكنيسه واستخدمته
الكنيسه للتفسير الكتاب المقدس الى ان
سقطت الكنيسه ولكن كانت اوروبا عنده مشكله
الاقطاع الاقطاع اتعب اوروبا
انتهت بشكل كبير
مهمه ولكن لهذا ترى حضرتك بانه الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه هي امتداد لاوروبا وهي
ااصل
باليسار لانه
مراحل الامريكان لا لما بنوا هاجروا
لامريكا الحقيقه تبنوا راسماليه الانسان
هو الانسان لما بقول لك ان الامريكي
متسامح وان يقبل بالغرب لا كان عندي في
قصص عنصريه انت تعرفينها كثير صارت في
امريكا لكن الراس ماليه اعطت مساحه
المهاجرين قابلت بدخول السوري ستيف جوبس
وابوه قبلت بالصوت افريكان همم الماس كنيش
يجي ويصنع ثرواته هنا هذا ما ممكن يصير في
دول كثير ليش ما الماس هاجر اوروبا ولا
هاجر فلسطين
من اصلا افريقيا
لماذا لماذا استاذ بسام لنرى ذلك مثلا او
لم نرى ذلك البعض يقول بانه الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه هي الاكثر انفتاحا هي
التي بنت لاعمده السياسه وهي التي كونت
ليستراتيجيات العالميه وهي التي نصبت
نفسها على راس هذا النظام العالمي لا يمكن
لا لروسيا ولا للصين ان تصل لهذا همم منصب
همم ما رايك
واسعد مساء مشاهدين قناه العربيه الكرام
اولا
الامبراطوريات تبنى على ثلاث العسكري
القوه العسكريه والقوه الاقتصاديه
والديولوجيا
الايديولوجيا التي قدمتها لنا الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه هي جيولوجيا همم كما
ذكر الاستاذ مازن الراسماليه
والعسكره شاركت في كل الحروب التي يمكن ان
تشارك بها بالعالم والقوه الاقتصاديه
الصناعيه كانت موجوده ولكن في الفتره
الاخيره مان يلاحظه ان اهم عوامل سقوط
الامبراطوريات هو امران اولا المشاركه في
الحروب العسكريه الخارجيه التي تنهج
سياسيا واقتصاديا ثانيا غياب الايديولوجيا
الايديولوجيه التي كانت تعتبر في الغرب
وهي القيم الغربيه وهي احترام الملكيه
احترام الشخصيه احترام الاديان كلها
تتلاشى امام اعيننا نرى ان هناك انقسام
داخلي من اهم العوامل التي يؤدي الى سقوط
الامبراطوريات في الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه وهو الانقسام المجتمع الامريكي
الى جمهور والديمقراطي وكلنا سيشاهد غدا
او بعد غدا هذا الانقسام الحاصل الذي قد
يؤدي في نهايه المطاف الى حرب اهليه هناك
بعض
قد تكون روح الديمقراطيه نفسها
ليست الديمقراطيه ليست بي ااا ااا اعتبار
الجمهوريين على سبيل المثال همم ارهابيون
داخليون كما اعلنتهم اعلنهم الديمقراطيون
عند وصولهم الى السلطه في عام 2020 دعيني
اكمل وجهه نظري بان هناك يعني خروج مخرج
للعسكر الامريكي من افغانستان هناك هزيمه
فيتنام هناك على عديد من النقاب وهناك
ايضا في المقابل نجد ان ال- ال- ال- القيم
الاوروبيه والامريكيه الغربيه باتت يعني
تزول ويحضر
وتوجد بدلا عنها القيم الجديده قيام
مجتمعين قيام الشواذ هذا الشيء لا يتفق مع
مجتمعاتنا ولا مع مجتمعات الغرب
المحافظ هناك دول ذات قيمه تظهر على
الساحه مثل روسيا والصين عسكريا اقتصاديا
وصناعيا موارد الطبيعيه هناك ازمه عالميه
للموارد ال- ال- ال- الموارد الطبيعيه
والغذائيه في المستقبل في نجد همم
صحيح صحيح وستكون هناك ازمات متتاليه اخرى
ستكون هناك يقول بعض حروب مياه وان لم
تبدا طبعا ونحت بعد ملفات سهله مع هذا
الموضوع ولكن انت طرحت اسماعيل طرحت روسيا
وطرحت الصين هل ترى بان روسيا او الصين
قادرتان احداهما او كلاهما على ان تقود
العالم تقود النظام العالمي
بكل تاكيد لا بكل تاكيد لا في الوضع
الراهن لا ولكن امريكا ستبقى دوله مقلوعه
الانياب ومقلمه الاظافر هي ستبقى دوله
عظيمه ولها قيمتها ولكن هناك تجمعات تظهر
لنا تجمع البريكس مثلا يرجع يظهر لنا
مجموعه منظمه شنغهاي هناك الهند الباكستان
لو نظرنا الى الموارد البشريه في هذه
الدول التي لا تعجبها القيم الغربيه التي
تنادي بها اليوم الغار ينادي بها الغرب
سنجل ان عدد سكانهم يفوق نصف الكره
الارضيه والموارد البشريه لا يستاهل بها
اما عن موضوع الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
واقتصادها فقد تجاوز دينها وحدود 30 مليون
دولار هذا يعني اننا نحن امام سقوط مدوي
سيكون
للسيطره والهيمن الامريكيه هذا لا يعني
انه سيلتغي دور الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه ولكن سيكون هناك عالم متعدد
الاخطاب قد يكون هناك كتلتين كتله الشرقيه
وقتل غربيه يكون تقاسم النفوس بينهما ومره
هذه تتفوق على هذه وهكذا ولكن في النهايه
سيكون هناك عالم متعدد الاقصاب لا مجال
لان العالم متعدد الاخطاء تحدث عنها حتى
بوتين في تصريحاته وطلب بذلك وكانت هناك
حتى تصريحات سياسيه همم اخرى بهذا الاتجاه
ولكن استاذ مازن همم حضرتك ترى بانه
الانسب في هذه المرحله همم الحساسه
والدقيقه التي يعيشها العالم ان يكون امام
جهه تقود العالم كالولايات المتحده
الامريكيه التي تقل العالم وضع عقود او
امام همم
متعدد الاقطاب كما يريده بوتين وكما تريده
كذلك الصين
نحن استاد ريم لا نحدد العالم من يختار لا
يوجد مقارب ولا منافس ولا قريب من
الولايات المتحده اذهب الكريم حديث
الاستاذ في موسكو ذكرنا الامبراطيات تقوم
ضمن العناصر تقوم على الايدولوجيا الصين
الحقيقه ليست شيوعيه ولا تعبر عن عيد عيد
ماركس في كتابه راس المال قال الصين لا
ينطبق عليها القوانين التي ذكرتها
والحقيقه نهضه الصين بدات بعد وفاه
الصين هذا ذهب
اعتقد زمن البرطريات امريكا نظام امريكا
نظام والمشاكل اللي تحدث فيها يعني هذا
النظام يتجدد ويواجه التغيرات والكاتب على
فكره في الكتابه ذكر مشكله الانقسام في
بعد الانتخابات بالصراحه على فكره انا
وانت ادركتي تغيرات كثيره ازمه السود عام
92 لما تعرض شرطي لرجل الاسود همم ما حدث
في انتخابات ترامب لكن تعود الان في
بريطانيا تتذكر حدثت اشياء في السبعينات
والثمانينات همم في عهد ثلاث اشهر وضعت
رفعت السومو ضربات في الشوارع لكنها ترجع
اقول لك شغله صحيح الديمقراطيه لها فضل
على انها تقدر انها تعاود الشعوب لكن من
عيوب ايضا الديمقراطيه انها تسمح ببعض
يعني ذكرها ارسطو في الكتابه السياسيه وصف
النظام الفاسد عند الغالبيه الاقليه تحاول
انها تسيطر على فكر الغالبيه بعض افكاره
لكنها تظهر افكار وتنتهي تبقى امريكا
متجدده توها حول العالم كسوق لهم ياتيها
كبر الشركات ان تكون مركز ابحاث لهم فهي
لا تاخذ صبغه امبراطوريه تخسر معارك في
الخارج خسرت كثير لكن بقت هي النظام اللي
يستطيع العالم ان يثق فيه ويجد موثوق اكثر
البديل يكون داخل الى الان للاسف هو داخل
العالم المجتمع الغربي صعب ان ياتي من
خارج المجتمع الغربي همم اتمنى ان يكون
حطيت اجابات على تساوي
يعلق اعتقد لانك لما تحدثت عن ان العالم
يثق في الولايات المتحده الامريكيه همم
احساس بانه هناك تفضل بسام
يعني اولا
الاحترام الخصوصيه والملكيه الشخصيه فقدته
القيم الامريكيه عندما تم احتجاز الاموال
الروسيه هذه سرقه موصوفه الاعتداء على
الاموال الخاصه
بالمواطنين الروس داخل امريكا وبالمجتمع
الغربي هذه كلها تنافي الايديولوجيه او
الديمقراطيه واحترام خصوصيه الملكيه
المتعالها متعامل فيها في الغرب هذا كله
يؤدي الى يعني
نفور
وتمرد الاصوات يعني نجد مثلا هناك دول همم
كانت لا تنسوا على همم مواجهه الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه اليوم تدافع عن سيادتها
لانها فهمت انها هي قد تستهدف اذا ما
تعرضت مصالحها مع الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه هناك اصوات تخرج لنا وتقول لا
انا اريد سيادتي على اراضيه اريد ساده على
قراري هذا الموضوع مهم للغايه يعني ان
نفهم ان العالم ما قبل العمليه العسكريه
في اوكرانيا باك ليس كما بعده لان روسيا
القت التحدي للغرب وقالت لا لن نقبل
سندافع عن سيادتنا هذا يعني ان هناك دول
تجرات الصين بدات تدعم روسيا في موقف انا
لا اقول ان روسيا ستحل مكان الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه بكل تاكيد ولكن انا
اقول ان هناك تجمع شرقي سيواجه التجمع
الغربي الذي يعني تبنى قيم مجتمع علميهم
هذا المجتمع الذي لا يتوافق مع كل القيم
الانسانيه ال- ال- ال- الالهيه يعني
عبر التاريخ كنا نحترم ان هناك اب وام
اليوم يقولون لك همم هناك انواع يعني
للبشر من من لا اريد ان اذكرهم على شاشه
عربيه يعني ولكن الكل فهم عليه هذا
الموضوع يعني يؤدي بالطبع الى ان شاء الله
كبير في المجتمع الدولي وشرق كبير في
القائمه ههه
اعود لك ساعود لك هو يطلب حق قناه استاذ
بسيوني الى النفور تحدثت حذرتك عن النفوذ
واضيف صحيح وساضيف على ما قلته صحيح
وساضيف على ما قلته وسؤال لك هنا استاذ
مازن ساضيف على ما قاله ضيفي من موسكو ما
يقوله بعض المراقبين بعض المراقبين لا
يتحدثون فقط عن النفور من الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه همم على اثر ملفات
اقتصاديه وماليه ولكن كذلك يتحدثون عن
الخراب الذي ادت به الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه كل ما تدخلت في شان ما العراق
افغانستان من بين هذه الامثله اضف على ذلك
بان الولايات المتحده الامريكيه لم تقدم
وعدا بحمايه من تسميهم حلفائها ونجحت
ونفذت ما وعدت به الاتفاق الايراني همم
فاشل كما اسمه مراقبون خير دليل على ذلك
كيف ترد على جمله هذه الاسئله باختصار
انت بس خلطتي الامور بس نفكر
الجزيره
حسب المعايير الدوليه وقانون من القوانين
الدوليه هذا يعتبر غزو يطبق عليهم
التامين الارصده اتذكر لما غزل العراق
الكويت في نفس اليوم الامريكي تجميد كل
الحسابات العراقيه فهي ما هي تطبق على
دوله مرتكبه انتهاءك ارجع للقطه اذا ما
تفضلت الثانيه الصين تفضل يا استاذ اسامه
لكن الصين محايد سلبي يعني لا يعطي الغرب
ما يريد من الحصار الصين لا تقف مع احد او
ضد احد مع الا الان علاقاتها مع الولايات
المتحده وعلاقتها معنا الصين عندها 1000
مليون لا تتحمل لا تتحمل اي حصان ولا تريد
اي حصار 40% من غذاء العالم المغسله في
الصين الصين عندها وجع مثل الوجع الامريكي
بسعر الطاقه وهي مساله الجوع لما مات 30
مليون صيني عن و50 لذلك ما تدخل في تصادم
ممكن يتحول الى ازمات حصار وتتورط بمعسكر
هذا ذكاء صيني انت ذكرتي بعد كذا ان
الولايات المتحده وضحت حلفاءها اصلا من
خطا انه حلفاء هيكونوا يسيرون كان بشكل
عام خلف الولايات المتحده وانشاء تطور
السياسه السعوديه انها تاخذ مصالحها اولا
التنميه
عرفات في كل شيء
همم المباشره والعاميه هناك مصالح تاتي
اول حتى حلفاء امريكا الاوروبيين يضعون
مصالحهم قبل مصالح امريكا من هم الذين
يضيعون ده الحقيقه الدول اللي ما عندها
قيادات الدول التي لا يوجد عندها قياده
مركزيه لكن دول اللي عندها استراتيجيه
ورؤيه لا ترضى اسرائيل اكبر حديث امريكي
يعني اسرائيل تنهار بدون الفوتي الامريكي
الحاله مع ذلك في داخلها في تفاصيله
خلافات قويه وكانت نتنياهو علاقته سيئه
اوباما وعلاقته
فلا يعني هذا انك تطيع الولايات المتحده
النظام المتجدد عندهم القدره في المعايير
الراسما ومؤسساته العاليه في الشفافيه انه
يحافظ على دايمو وقابلها العالم كانظام
تختلف معهد كدوله لكن كان نظام تجاري كان
نظام عالمي واي منطقه العالم يكفي ان
عملتها هي 45% من تجاره العالم هذه دليل
الثقه بها العمده ثقه العمله هي ثقه هذا
الشيخ صنع السوق يعني ما جاب القوه ما جاب
الفرق
هي اللي صديقها ولغه الاقتصاد ولغه المال
والاعمال كما يقول البعض خلاصه القول ان
كان لك تعليق سير بسام واختم بالقول هل
يمكن ان ارى يوما ااا هذا النطاق لعالم
متعدد الاقطاب تعتقد تفضل
في العالم هو كل ممارسه نهايه
الامبراطوريات ابتداء من الرومانيه
وانتهاء من بريطانيا عندما لا تجد من
تردده من يردها تبدا بالبلطجه وهذه
البلطجي تهدي الى نهايه هذه الامبراطوريه
وهزم لاحظنا على مدى 30 سنه الاخيره عندما
مارست او امريكا كل ما بيوسعها من بلطجه
ضد الشعوب المستضعفه وضد حتى الدول
الكبيره والاقليميه الكبيره والعظمى
انصحها التعبير وهذا سيؤدي حتما الى
انحسار دورها
كراائده للعالم وانما سيصبح على متعدد
الاخطاب لامريكا له بها دور ولكن ليس دور
شرطي او حد للعالم
باختصار استاذ مازن يمكن ان يكون هناك
عالم متعدد الاقدام
اكثر منك
شكرا لكم
مشاهدينا السلام عليكم